[Music]
other news now russia is acknowledging
huge losses in ukraine's northern harkiv
region moscow admits its forces have
been outnumbered in the past week with
ukraine retaking swathes of land
well since early september ukrainian
troops have advanced rapidly areas that
took russia months to seize have been
retaken in just days
kiev's forces say they've forced russian
troops nearly back to the northern
border
ukraine says it's also made gains in the
south near hassan but at a slower pace
but in response to those gains ukraine
says russia is attacking power and water
supplies in the hakuva region officials
say missile strikes caused blackouts in
several areas including hockey city an
estimated nine million people were
affected including in areas controlled
by russia
abdulhamid is live for us in har kiev so
what's the latest you're hearing about
the ukrainian advances and and any
russian response
well the ukrainians are continuing their
counter-offensive but we actually as
media when it comes to this military
operation we have very
little access if any uh at all and i
think that the thinking among the
military here is that um they will
control the message and that the media
really reporting can only be disruptive
so what we know is what we get on uh
from these statements uh the latest we
heard through these statements is that
the ukrainian army is indeed in
uh they are conflicting reports on
whether it's in total control of that
town or not but that is a huge blow for
russia uh because izum was basically the
stronghold of russia in this
northeastern part of the country and it
was
it was a command and center it was also
the logistical hub so certainly a huge
loss we are also hearing that the
russians are
rather the ukrainians are advancing
towards
the the border in some parts they have
reached the border with russia in other
parts it appears that they would be
pushing north toward that northern
northeast section of the border um but
more than that at this point we cannot
tell you
except that the mood is very upbeat
among the ukrainians 3 000 square
kilometers captured in a matter of days
10 days or so a huge success
for them that has taken everyone by
surprise and certainly the russian
soldiers and hodder with that upbeat
mood then how significant could this be
for the war as a whole
well it could be a turning point um this
is the first time we really see the
ukrainian army
on the offensive in such a way
as you mentioned there are two counter
offensives going on one in this part of
the country and one in the southern
region where also we do not have any uh
much information uh but there are many
factors before really the ukrainians
could uh sort of
celebrate all of this the first one is
how well will they be able to keep uh
all this territory they they gain some
people say it's so quick and it's such a
vast area that they wonder you will need
very strong supply lines now the
russians are saying some of those who
are now crit openly criticizing uh their
military command
there are saying that actually the one
up that the ukrainian have over the uh
russians is the fact that they have very
effective resupply lines now it it
so that has to continue as you have to
also understand that from there they
will try to go further south and further
east towards the donbass region where
again you will have to have it's a huge
huge part of this uh country the other
factor is what is what will russia do at
this point the ministry of defense in
moscow has uh said that it has pulled
out its troops towards a small river uh
uh the western flank of that small river
it says that it has pulled out from some
8 000 square kilometers so basically the
whole kharkiv region go going all the
way to dumbass but russia is still here
russia still has superiority when it
comes to airstrikes for example here in
kharkiv since friday there have been
about 30 airstrikes anyone you speak to
here which says that that is more than
it has been for many months at least
over the summer and people are worried
because of the proximity of the city to
the border some 40 kilometers for
example that this city will see more and
more airstrikes so russia does have
capabilities till does have air
superiority can hit all the way to leve
and then it will have to do something it
will have to have a next move the
kremlin under a lot of pressure at the
moment getting open criticism which is
something that has been rare since the
beginning of this war so really what
happens next depends on all of these
factors before you can think of the next
stage
and honda with um
those strikes you you talk about we we
saw you reporting uh in the middle of a
recent blackout i mean you were in a in
a basement a dark basement is the power
back on
well the power has been back on
on and off wherever you go a bit around
the city you ask people uh it depends on
the area it was a huge strike some on
social media there is talk that it was
actually uh there were two uh
what the what people here call critical
infrastructure that were hit uh they
expect that that will happen uh more and
more it's not only the power that has
gone off it's also the water for people
that has gone off we were talking
earlier uh to an old lady she was
sitting in front of her building and she
had no gas and she had no water she had
had only a few hours of electricity she
was still in the in the dark and you
could probably see around me there's no
one absolutely on the street very
few people at this time yesterday there
were more people on the street and
that's probably because of that power
blackout you won't see any street lamps
that are on
so certainly a very eerie atmosphere
very dark and in that during the night
in the darkness there were several
airstrikes uh overnight so people would
expect the same to happen
this coming evening
abdulhamid reporting live for us there
thank you